hugging face releases a course you can
now play gta inside of an ai's mind
and spot turns one welcome to ml news
[Music]
good evening huggingface the famous nlp
startup releases a course that teaches
you
how to use their models libraries
and other code they release this goes
from
introduction of how to use transformers
and what transformers
are how to fine-tune them to the diving
in
area about the data sets and tokenizers
library
up to advanced things like speeding up
training
and training your custom training loop
of course the course is highly
integrated with the
hogging face ecosystem but it requires
quite little and it seems like a good
place if you don't know a lot but you
know how to program
you can get into deep learning and
specifically nlp pretty easily
with that course so the course consists
of videos
collabs code demonstrations and so on
this should be specifically interesting
for
practitioners or data scientists that
know a little bit about machine learning
but really want to get into the
applications
of retrained nlp models maybe you want
to fine tune them a little bit
give it a try check it out it's up there
for free
next up the popular youtuber scentdex
releases
a gta version that is played entirely
in the mind of a neural network all the
environment you see
is entirely generated by a neural
network that responds
to your action the network has been
trained by random agents driving around
on this stretch of road so you can't
actually go further than this
to run the demo you do need a gpu that
is cuda capable
though the code is available and you're
probably very free to extend this
to also work on cpu and extend the level
beyond this stretch of road through all
of this experience the neural network
actually learns something about the
physics of the game itself even though
you never teach it physics so go check
out the demo
if you can check out the code give the
video a watch and a like
i'll provide the links to the github in
the description of this video
and you're able to take it from there
next up facebook is testing ai to get
you to stop
fighting in its groups cnn business
rights apparently facebook is
introducing new moderator tools
for group admins that get notified
whenever there is a
conflict argument happening in their
groups this allows them to go in
and limit how often users can post
or maybe block some users in order to
de-escalate the conflict i love the
examples they give here
going like lol what shut up you're so
dumb
stop talking about organic food you
idiot
idiots if this nonsense keeps happening
i'm leaving the group
i mean i get they can't show the worst
arguments happening on facebook
in their product demo it's still kind of
fun now of course this is not the first
time
that moderation tools are used or that
ai is supposed to
help moderation you can always be a bit
skeptical about
a.i regulating speech somewhere as long
as this is just used to send
notifications to moderators
it's uh one thing if this is also used
then to automatically moderate content
i would be a little more skeptical also
the bigger problem with these things
i think is always the conflict between
are we simply detecting toxicity
and conflicting opinions or are we
detecting opinions
that we don't like now today's social
media giants have a bit of a tendency to
be in that second category
and that's something that i would advise
strongly against
however there is an easier way to
moderate toxicity on facebook if you
don't want to get into toxic arguments
on facebook i suggest you just don't use
facebook
no one else does you're welcome
you know on this show which is an
irregular show
we do get our fair share of comments and
feedback and
thank you all so much for that some or
though just
a little bit silly like this one
so now that i think about it
this evening with that strong gradient
from the north
in this area huge actions
and in this this little piece
high high accuracy
so take your time train efficiently
and you know avoid huge saddles
huge shuttles are bad for you also don't
don't take your kids saddle points are
dangerous
dangerous for you and your family for me
it's all and now the word
all right the washington post writes an
autonomous ship's
first effort to cross the atlantic shows
the difficulty
of the experiment apparently there is a
ship called the
mayflower 400 that is built by a british
company and is supposed to cross the
atlantic ocean
in a purely autonomous fashion now i'm
not sure how much of this
is technically a i as it seems to be
mostly
a lot of control theory and classic
robotics but it is an autonomous vehicle
so pretty cool at that
so the applications of autonomous ships
are going to be according to this
article
going and measuring some chemical
composition of
far away ocean lands ocean waters
generally
doing reconnaissance and listening to
whale sounds
and surely there are no other
applications for this
not at all can't strap anything to it
then you can then
however there is a problem in that the
ship had a technical difficulty
and had to return to shore so the actual
crossing of the atlantic
will have to wait for another couple of
weeks it seems now there is a website
where you can track
in real time what the ship is doing so
as you can see right
here this is the route the ship was
supposed to take with a few
historical landmarks of when famous
other ships
sank and the target is in massachusetts
now what you can also see
is the path that the actual ship took
until
now so it is still apparently out in the
ocean somewhere
and you can see the point where it had
to turn around
but it seems like it had some problems
already before
what exactly happened here dotted line
is the course
and it just kind of decided to get away
from it
and then of course here it had to turn
around due to the technical difficulties
however once it turned around they just
decided to go
into a couple of formations just for
giggles i guess so is it now still
going to america or is it returning to
shore
no one knows it seems like our long-term
goal of building
self-deciding ai has finally succeeded
and the ai just decides to stay in the
water for a little bit longer
all right next news pytorch releases the
1.9
release among other things it migrates
some of previously
experimental libraries too stable such
as torch.linux
and complex autograd specifically
torch.linux is supposed to
replicate whatever numpy dot linux has
in it and bring this to pi torch tensors
this should enable
a lot more easy applications of classic
linear algebra routines
in pytorch natively another big
improvement
is the mobile interpreter of pytorch
which makes it possible to reduce
binaries that you ship to mobile devices
by up to 75 for typical applications
so if you want to get into mobile
development with pytorch
now is a good time to check out the new
1.9
release there are also a lot of other
improvements for example
updates to the pytorch rpc framework
that allows you to send data around
between distributed workers
so check it out give it a try let's go
on
[Music]
alright zdnet writes i just watched
mcdonald's new ai drive through
and i've lost my appetite so apparently
this tick tock by user suit master 2000
is going around showing what the new
automated drive-through machines at
mcdonald's are capable of
welcome to mcdonald's we're currently
serving a limited menu
so please review the menu before
ordering let me know what i can get for
you
can i get two medium oreo mcflurries
all right would you like anything else
that's it okay
your total will be 658 please go forward
now people
are calling this robot a bit dystopian
or whatnot
as idina here writes the voice is
exactly the same robot voice you've
heard in every disturbing sci-fi movie
it's as if siri's daughter has just got
her first job
welcome to mcdonald's it reminds me of
uh glados in
in portal so instead of this feeling
dystopian i get a bit of a warm feeling
in my
heart but as you can see like the
recognition of speech
works just fine and that's honestly all
i want from an ordering robot i don't
want it to give me
heartwarming emotions or anything like
this i'm just fine with that but it kind
of shows you
how hard it is to actually make a human
interaction
ai work and it seems like the more human
you make it the less people
are forgiving of mistakes no one bothers
if
a automated train voice takes a little
too long to announce the next station
but when it's
supposed to be more human people get
freaked out if it's like
just a little off it's a very special
phenomenon but honestly i'm not too
bothered
[Music]
next news cnbc writes artificial
intelligence won't replace the role of
financial advisors
ubs ceo says
so apparently ubs ceo ralph hamer said
artificial intelligence is better suited
to handling day-to-day functions like
opening an account or executing trades
apparently he said
that if it comes to these basic tasks um
ai is better and by ai i guess he just
means
software where is a.i in opening an
account
or executing a trade so apparently the
opinion here is that
our financial advisors should be
supported by the technology
and their advisors they should advise so
the advisors shouldn't take care of
low-level tasks such as opening accounts
instead they should be informed by the
ai to make
decisions he also said ubs is looking to
adopt a netflix experience where clients
can access a dashboard
of different research and product like
everybody wants dashboards why
why like i get it but nah technologies
like ai can help
financial advisors figure out the best
way to serve clients according to hamers
if you ask me this just sounds like an
industry that's a bit in decline
and a bit threatened by the general rise
of digitalization and software
and ai so all the tasks he describes
that ai is able to do
is pretty much things that just software
are able to do while ai is going to
actually replace these humans so this
kind of rests on the assumptions
that you think we still want to be
advised by those bankers
now if memory serves me right didn't you
just kind of recently advise everyone to
buy into the housing markets
and then not tell everyone that
everything is full of crap until you
sold your own stuff
and then plunged the entire world into a
big recession yeah are you sure we want
to be advised by those people
i think i'll take my chances with an ai
any day
thank you all right jurgen schmidt uber
released
a new blog post celebrating the 90th
birthday
of court goodell's 1931 paper which he
says
laid the foundations of theoretical
computer science and the theory of
artificial intelligence
now whatever opinion of schmidt hoover
you have he is a pretty good
historian and his blog posts are
generally
quite interesting to read so it's pretty
short and concise
and filled with references that allow
you to go deeper if you want to
i invite you to go check it out and read
it up
next news facebook releases ogli an
oddly named
data augmentation library to help build
more robust ai models
data augmentation is an important topic
especially in things like computer
vision research
but the library allows you to go even
beyond that into nlp data augmentation
and others so if you're doing anything
that uses augmentations
i invite you to check out this library
[Music]
all right a team from mit the allen
institute for ai and microsoft research
have released a set of programming
puzzles along with
a paper and there is a big github repo
filled
with puzzles that are supposed to
accelerate the research into ai coding
so ai that is able to solve coding
problems
in these problems the ai gets a piece of
code which contains a function
that it has to satisfy and the rest is
up to the imagination of whoever builds
the algorithm the cool thing about this
approach
is that it's pretty general so the
examples here contain things like towers
of hanoi
finding optimal strategies for
tic-tac-toe shortest path
problems and even some open problems in
computer science and mathematics
you can even contribute your own puzzles
and i think the repository is meant as
sort of a collective
effort to collect pieces of code that
ai might be able to solve in the future
or that ai is already able to solve
if you're into ai generated code and ai
generated
problem solutions check out this
repository and try yourself to come up
with an
ai that solves some of these problems
and last news spot turns one beloved
machine
dog and carrier of various military
items
boston dynamics robot spot turns one
year old
as deployed in the real world so boston
dynamics has released a little video
of where spot is used throughout the
world now of course there are some
pretty cool applications for this
technology
like it can go into mines and check out
dangerous areas
it can go into high voltage areas or
into chernobyl to measure radiation
and it seems like the applications of
drones like these
are pretty pretty numerous it can save a
lot of humans from doing
either very tedious work or very
dangerous work
now of course this being produced by
boss dynamics it displays the robot
in the best possible light but with any
technology
there are good applications there are
bad applications i think it's cool that
technology is being pushed forward
and i'd rather have spot in this world
than not so this was it for this week's
ml news i hope you enjoyed this one and
i'll see you
next time bye bye all right all right